bonsoir et bienvenue pour le
statut de cette somme le 13
décembre dans un instant les
principaux titres en images nous
reviendrons nous parlerons
santé notamment alors que la
ministre marisol touraine vient
de dévoiler aujourd'hui son
plan de lutte contre l'êta
déserts médicaux mais tout
d'abord ali se dessine
bonsoir à l'union sacrée comme
chaque semaine comme chaque
jeudi le point sur l'économie
avec vous ce sera dans une
demi-heure willard ce soir à la
page des fêtes de noël on va
parler de la sécurité chez les
commerçants du territoire
le renforcement dispositif crs
était terminée six meilleurs
équipements et des locaux pour
éviter cambriolages et
braquages la chronique de lait
condensé un des meilleurs à
suivre voici les titres à
présent en images les sujets
que nous allons développer les
dix ans de la maison médicale
de montigny-le-bretonneux
alors que la ministre de la
santé vient de présenter ses
mesures pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux des raisons
médicales
elles sont montrés en exemple
pour des emplois notamment les
urgences en plateau l'ordre des
médecins à l'origine du
dispositif
à l'apprentissage une formule
qui fonctionne et il en sera
question lors de la page
économie est également tout à
l'heure
les quarante de cfa d hiddink ne
formait c et l'apprenti cette
année en plan national va aussi
voir le jour pour renforcer
ces résultats les commerçants
et leur sécurité réunion
organisée par la chambre de
commerce un système d'alertés
sms pour être mis en place les
commerçants signaleront chaque
incident mais sur un portail web
sécurisé
enfin l'opération collecte de
jouets proposés par ace qui bus
comme chaque année le
transporteur depuis 10 996
organise cette fois-ci quinze
mille jouets ont été
redistribuées une dizaine
d'associations caritatives
locales
et puis cette information à
vous donner a été
officialisée en milieu de
l'après-midi
à la commission départementale
de coopération apèrs communale
se réunit en préfecture le
mercredi vous m découvrez la
carte des futures
intercommunalités pour
l'ensemble du département le la
caisse qui communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin de modifications
de périmètre
pas d'entrée de nouvelles
communes on peut aussi noter que
deux intercommunalités secret
et celle de plaisir les clés du
projet et puis également de
mort par quoi nière
cette carte devait être
arrêté avant le 31 décembre
ces périmètres
ne sont moins pour certains que
transitoire et ne pourront pas
encore évolué dans le cadre de
la loi
et du 29 février 2011 qui
prévoit une clause de revoyure
ans 2015 on passe à la santé
bonsoir docteur à la famille
cela vous êtes le président de
l'association des médecins de
trois villages à
montigny-le-bretonneux
aujourd'hui la ministre marie
seule touraine qui a dévoilé
un plan d'attaquants 12% pour
lutter contre les déserts
médicaux ces zones où les
médecins de s'installer plus
parmi nous
les mesures je vais vous en
donner les grandes lignes de ce
que vous avez peut-être pas eu
le temps d'en prendre
connaissance tout au long de la
journée
vous étiez à l'université
versailles saint-quentin pour
donner des décombres vendée
alors parmi ces différentes
mesures 100 % des étudiants en
médecine générale en stage
dans un cabinet libéral des
praticiens hospitaliers aussi
principalement des spécialistes
qui pourront venir travailler
à temps partiel dans les
structures libérale sans perdre
pour autant
leur statut de salarié et puis
les incitations la financière
aussi pour les premières
installations votre avis sur les
quelques mesures je viens de
citer peut-être aussi être que
ces 100 % d'étudiants en
médecine qui vont aller la
pratiquer des stages pour chaque
jour c'est ce que je connais
le son pour ce rendez-vous
étudiante
aider le petit général fondée
déjà leur stage en médecine
générale c'est vrai pour toute
la france
actuellement je pense que j'ai
une petite confusion
avec peut-être les étudiants
de deuxième cycle si m
le port qui effectivement
l'ensemble des stages ne sont
pas couverts mu
si on passe de le devenir et
pour de pas moins de centres
sont déjà
chaque chose sont déjà
engagés en tout cas très beau
travail tout 907 sa réforme ces
discussions qui sont en cours à
ce que le gouvernement
sur cette question du dr
médicaux que l'on peut réussir
là où les précédents
gouvernements on te souhaite que
j'aime qu'on me dise
ils peuvent aussi bajule
commodities j'ai pas eu autant
de doutes
vous maîtrisez l'ensemble des
délits routiers ont été
proposés
aujourd'hui donc je découvre
avec
avec ce que vous venez de dire
% à priori je pense si des
tunes de bon
comme de bon ton compte tenu de
l'afp
l'évolution de la démographie
médicale sur l'ensemble du
territoire
de prendre des mesures qui pour
son allié et
dans le sens le plus pur
investissement du chantier qu'on
a perdu ses ailes
ces deux dernières années
pour ce qui est clair
aujourd'hui c'est que les
déserts médicaux coûteux
le coup au ventre qu'on désigne
un petit peu
le moteur
dans le territoire
le plus tôt à la campagne
plutôt dans des zones qui se
désertifient l'événement
équiterre de leurs habitants
pour bientôt
le rejoindre
des zones de combat pas
l'habitude de considérer comme
des assassins et des partisans
du dirigeant du réseau le tout
assaisonné toutes les envies
rapidement qu'on adore
de cinq à dix ans je pense que
l'ensemble du territoire sera
reconstruit comme d habitude
si effectivement les mesures
appropriées soient prises
avec vos confrères de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous
avez fondé en 2000 de la
première maison médicale de
garde en france
pour vous êtes aussi pour cela
qu'on est dans les limites de ce
père de famille de france
était une des premières en
tout cas au niveau niveau
français aussi vous vous êtes
attaqués à réorganiser
justement aussi
la médecine le chiffre de cette
édition 10 10 forcément
puisque c'est votre dixième
anniversaire
une maison médicale qui
fonctionne bien vous allez nous
détailler tout cela tout
d'abord nous allons revenir sur
la soirée
organisée la semaine dernière
pour célébrer cette première
décennie d'existence
des images pédophiles
regrouper en un seul lieu des
professionnels de la santé
capable de prendre en charge les
patients durant les heures de
fermeture des cabinets médicaux
de ville
une idée portée au début des
années 2000 par l'amicale des
médecins des trois villages de
montigny-le-bretonneux la 2012
dix ans après son ouverture la
maison médicale de garde veille
sur 233 milles habitants de
saint-cyr-l'école amani les
hameaux en passant par l encours
enfin grâce à 40 médecins
généralistes volontaires
et au baiser
une préoccupation éthique qui
était celle de pouvoir observer
sur l'oppression
de la communauté
mais une vision de ce que
pouvait être la permanence de
soins à une certaine époque
gagnant pas loin
dijon
par contre les 35 heures
d'affilée qu'on veut dire
aujourd'hui
ça paraît complètement foot
mais c'est quand même ce qui
s'est passé c'est le cas
en plus ça paraissait normal
plus de temps à l'occasion de
la soirée d'anniversaire de la
maison médicale nicolas about
ancien médecin maire de la
ville en fonction à l'époque
à rappeler ce qui l'a poussé
à mettre à disposition des
locaux de sa commune c'était un
peu moderne parce que
d'ailleurs on avait tendance à
dire mais les médecins à
alimenter un se débrouiller
la santé publique ça relève
des politiques
et comme l'état nation n'est
plus totalement véritablement
cette dimension il était
important que les collectivités
locales
se prennent en main
pour répondre à ce problème
de garde qui devenait vraiment
extrêmement dangereux
reste que cette réussite
suscite des convoitises la
maison médicale pourrait se
voir imposer par l'agencé
régionale de santé de couvrir
un territoire encore plus vaste
les médecins se disant inquiet
les élus partagent leurs
craintes si on rajoute une de
vos passions je crois que l'on
va
retombé dans les problèmes qui
sont générés aujourd'hui au
niveau des exigences
spectaculaire
donc je n'ai pas envie que se
passe comme ça la maison
médicale est installé à
proximité de la police
municipale les patients ne
peuvent excéder qu'après un
appel auprès du cnosf
l'acteur a annoncé en
présentant dans ce reportage on
va parler d'eux la formation
médicale avant l'ouverture de
cette maison dite médicale aux
conditions de travail des
assises de la médecine
presque inconcevable que vous me
disait combien d'heures de garde
pouviez faire après avoir
travaillé tôt dans la journée
version du tube the booze
une journée complète une nuit
complète d'une journée
complète
e on avait 36
parfois 40
de garde suite donc de la
tactique et vous vous la tension
devrait être soutenu
l'avion considéré à l'époque
comme normal qu'on puisse être
médecins de soigner des gens
avoir la responsabilité 2 la
vive
devenu une passion pour le
dans le même état côté
buteurs
la prise en charge de fonctions
jusqu'à la fin
normand pratique
effectivement on est tous c'est
pas concevable c'est plus
concevable
aujourd'hui cette maison
médicale a véritablement
permis de de réduire cette
durée du travail pour un
concept est possible comment
comment fonctionne en fait la
maison médicale de garde
charles la maison médicale
fonctionne
tous les jours
après la fermeture de cabinet
à travers elle fonctionne le
week-end
à partir de samedi à 14 heures
et elle continue à travailler
les jours fériés de 8 heures
à minuit à 22 milliards levés
qui est pris part d'autres
médecins qui ont pour le titre
les médecins mobilier des
quilles
assure le nombre d'activités
plus limité parce qu'on avait
fait une petite étude l'époque
ont montré qu'en fin de compte
le maximum des actes été
réalisés ils étaient entre 8
heures et minuit
d'où l'idée qu'il était venu
lorsque société invention du
de l'association plus de faire
d'étranges de quatre heures
l'activité à peu près tous
les rats parce que foucault pas
non plus père de but qu'on a
quand même
toujours la journée de 12
heures réservation avec un
traitement très bonne journée
de travail qui furent
suffisantes
partager les responsabilités de
garden dans cette maison voilà
où mène 45 maintenant aux
médecins de se relayer
le temps la structure thé à
partir de 8 heures certains
d'entre nous qui vient prendre
le relais
des qualités qui sont fermés
la jusqu'à minuit appréciée
une autre association passer une
autre fiction qui gère des
médecins mobile les latics
yonhap
le maire un terrain d'action
beaucoup plus large
les tigers ont beaucoup de
passion
certains ne connaissent
peut-être pas cette maison
médicale areva continue à
expliquer comment comment elle
fonctionne puisque c'est son
10ème anniversaire le 10 mai si
c'était de sécuriser le lieu
ou pour le médecin c'est
important alors nous pouvons
exercer en toute sécurité
tout à fait alors
c'était une des
problématique pragmatique du
départ arrive
les gens étaient d'accord pour
venir pour revisiter le système
que
en europe et ailleurs qui était
devenu obsolète qui avait
justifié surplombe le degré
élevé et de renoncement il y a
je dis toujours
et pour cent dans cette
revisitation y avait le fait
qu'on puisse fonctionner
centre cup s 'ils ont veut de
sécurité
je dois dire que sûrement tunis
c'est pas une préoccupation
absolument majeur mais quand on
nous a proposé de traverser à
la police municipale on s'est
dit que c'était une oeuvre une
proximité qui était heureux
hasard et j'ai moi-même un
bloc-notes ce même bloc de
bâtiments idée
plus globalement m
sur passe très bien et
on est très contents que la
plus riche que ce que tu te
souviens que les conditions on
n'a jamais eu à déplorer que
ce soit pour mieux prévenir
ceci dit derrière c'est par un
médecin que je peux dire que tu
n'es pas là cet est tout
trouvé
c'était finalement assez facile
à mettre en place nous avait un
très bon accueil de deux essais
ici
on a entendu nicolas de
tavernost un nombre important
seul été facile parce que lui
avait dit que l'on pouvait tirer
des journaux locaux qui de
sources qu'ils ont accompagné
avec qui on n'a pas eu beaucoup
de hauts beaucoup de soin d'eux
la commande d'argumenter ap en
pratique c'est un peu compliqué
parce que il a fallu mettre en
oeuvre
un certain nombre de degrés
il crée des dossiers club de
monter des projets et cetera
on l'appelait aussi été
largement révisés et départ
les collectivités locales
les heureuses c'est vrai que
quand on met en perspective qui
s'est passé ailleurs
le russe a été facile
de relativement en pratique on
avait dans l'idée à l'époque
le sco avait montée pouvaient
être des dix ans pour la liste
nationale et d'ailleurs c'est un
peu comme ça qu'on avait
présentée
en pratique aujourd'hui encore
on est les seuls à fonctionner
comment fonctionne dans
l'ensemble de france et
j'entends des lames de la
responsable presse
selon ce dernier la santé
c'est que le
de même en france et pas
beaucoup d'expériences
similaires
pensez-vous comme un modèle
justement aujourd'hui le modèle
que vous avez développé et mis
en place pourrait faire office
de référence
celui-ci
le pays
les acteurs étaient les mêmes
les autres ça c'est pas du tout
péjoratif pour eux ce qui se
passait bien c'est que là on a
une conjonction d'événements
de rencontre
de collision de deux
d'harmonie entre les les les
médecins et les collectivités
locales
le faire tous les gens qu'on a
rencontrés que
en gros la tâche a été
compliqué parce que c'est
toujours compliqué de
s'attaquer à des
le paradigme comme ça qui sont
c'est à l'effigié de
dans le marbre depuis des
décennies nez pour cent
relativement ici c'était quand
même plutôt tranquille quoi
plus tôt aujourd'hui vous
couvre un bassin de plus de 230
mille personnes sur quelque 25
comines
votre crainte on en a révoqué
rapidement évoqué rapidement
tout alors ses devoirs se
massant s'élargir dans 25
communes
avant de nous expliquer pourquoi
vous êtes inquiets
on a tout même posé la
question à quelques cinq
continents et ce que vous
connaissez de cette maison
médicale qui fait
son dixième anniversaire
il jugea que j'ai failli à
cerner je sais qu'il vient
d'arriver
et je suis très fier même pour
sa petite taille
une association il a pris un
extincteur et une écurie il ya
toujours une permanence
oui je connais les syndicats le
savent surtout celle des
gardiens
pour le dimanche
j'ai déjà utilisé
en urgence le soir
ou enfin de
de journée
mais à des horaires
je sais qu'il existe
actuellement
jeudi soir
toujours dans la nuit on peut en
faire ayew
à voir à faire c'est un
endroit où on peut aller se
faire soigner la nuit par
exemple lorsque m soucy
et qu'on ne peut pas demander à
son médecin
de famille mais ces aides comme
un cabinet avec des médecins
associés mettre quelqu'un peut
toujours trouver quelqu'un
elle fait partie des habitudes
cette maison médicale de garde
que vous avez mis en place en
parler d'un bassin qui va
s'élargir
à l'abattre communes ont
entendu parler et serait
intéressé pour autant de
dispositifs que vous avez en
massant déjà largement je vais
pas citer l'ensemble des 25
communes et yassin sur l'école
dampierre tous eu également
pour ce qui est déjà un petit
peu moins de deux ans
montigny-le-bretonneux l'a6a
s'élargit véritablement comme
le souhaiterait l'aérostat
agences régionales de santé
cette news intitulée ça remet
en cause la pérennité de
l'ensemble mais ici c'est une
attitude d'autant plus que je
pense que c'est
le cas des charges la rs état
cahier des charges qui est
proposé on voit ici est tel
qu'il est expliqué en fête
la problématique
on retrouve jourd'hui au nahd 25
secteur qui regroupe
qui regroupe
d'un certain nombre de communes
nous on avait voulu quand même
centralisée un peu l'action des
médecins sur la vie nouvelle
initialement ce qu'elle prend
des tons que c'était nous qui
nous allions cours on a élargi
parce que comme on a eu de
l'aide également 2 la
communauté d'agglomération où
on a eu de l'aide de dede de
demain sans mettre de l'ordre
dans les rues et les maisons
concernées voilà le mot de
l'armée
puisque je suis à dampierre
saint-cyr aussi par exemple
rapidement on est devenus
incontournables de scruter % et
la seule réponse apportée
pour patienter téléphoner au
centre 15 qui est le centre qui
régule les appels
donc logiquement on avait pas
d'autre solution que de pouvoir
répondre aux appels de gens
quitter dans la difficulté et
qui avait des problèmes de
santé qui est
trouvez pas sur leur territoire
de réponse adaptée à l'ordre
pour l'heure ce site
mais ceci dit
c'est clair que
le menu à vocation initiale
s'était pas d'ouvrir furent les
sept secteurs maintenant que la
rs propose
et de se retrouver avec une
une bombe
ducky verre de derbouka l'autre
qui se souvient de la maison
départementale la garde civile
oui femmes
le médecin se profile jeudi des
piles sans compter que nous on a
une dimension qui est une
dimension associative locale
avec que m
des capacités de gestion et des
médecins
qui veut aussi sont demandeurs
de venir participer à l'article
ce qui se passe ici
la session sera pas la même et
pour cent
la proximité
la mule les rapports qui pour
ceux qui sont établis entre les
collègues je serais
probablement pas les mêmes dans
un calendrier déjà que s'est
fixé pour cette mise en place
à l'entraînement mon idée
d
et je pense que
le gérant des voleurs est à la
semaine prochaine sur les
voitures son concepteur parce
que prochaine
le jeu pour ce que je ferai le
comprendre
le sondes
la fois des médecins
ceux qui se sont déjà
appliquées iteere
si on montrait que ce qu'il
avait mis en place qualificative
on sera fixé très rapidement
sur le sort de cette maison
médicale ce mardi
tout est à refaire son sort on
sera fixé rapidement eu lieu
il est de toute façon je crois
pas que l'histoire
aujourd'hui pour les médecins
qui sont appliquées
qui soit d'actualité que
dupuis s'ouvrira plus large que
ce combat mis en place jusqu'à
présent
merci docteur hassani la maison
médicale de garde qui fête ses
10 ans je rappelle que vous
pouvez
y accéder en tant que patient
qu'après un appel pour que
centre 15 c'est le médecin
régulateur du samu qui peut
vous orienter merci à vous dans
un instant la fête juive des
lumières s'éteignent cas en ce
moment à rabat va nous en dire
plus il est après la chronique
de l'économie une demi-heure ce
soir pour comprendre
pourquoi l'apprentissage est un
bon moyen de s'insérer dans le
monde du travail m mais aussi
pour voir que les commerçants
s'organisent face à
l'insécurité
années déjà nouvelle approche
solidarité avec ce reportage de
valérie auris hybride qui ont
encore fait la collecte des
jouets distribués
pas parce qu'ils n'eussent pri
terminée les associations vont
l'être redistribuées
dans les prochains jours
tout doit disparaître
près de quinze mille jouets ont
été collectés cette année
dans le cadre de l'action
organisée par se quittent plus
depuis 1996
les données ont été
principalement dans les écoles
élémentaires et les écoles
maternelles
avec toute une démarche
pédagogique avant des
instituteurs qui explique
pourquoi il faut venir donner
des enfants donner un jouet qui
l'ont aimée mais que maintenant
il est passé au niveau de la
région
donc que ça c'est une première
collecte et ensuite banques on a
aussi beaucoup de gens qui
viennent donner directement dans
le bus 60 personnes qui vont
acheter des jouets neufs on a
énormément de joueurs
les deux sociétés
ils sont ensuite redistribués
à des associations caritatives
locales
après de premières pages
compétitivité
ces associations font le plein
avant de redonner elle-même aux
plus défavorisés
au sein de l'association bush et
pierre 150 enfants de 0 à 14
ans bénéficient de cette
collecte de jouets
on a beaucoup de familles
monoparentales debout mais
surtout celle de gens avec des
petites retraites
et puis même des couples qui
ont un petit salaire en premier
je voulais pour les petits
plus il a mon avis les enfants
de 0 à 13 ans mais là encore
en compte pour les plus petits
cette année encore et malgré
la crise
les plus démunis pour moi avoir
un véritable noël